c'est un peu la nuit une deux derrière
2,3 tel bouquet final la lumière
derrière
j'adore le nokia n9 pur view mais il ne
se vendra pas beaucoup ou pas assez
c'est plus ça l'idée en fait bon bah je
sais ça manque un peu de place que pour
vous faire mon titre de ma vidéo youtube
le concept je trouve vraiment bien mais
malheureusement j'ai peur se sont un peu
compliquées vous explique pourquoi
[Musique]
dans la famille nokia je voudrais le
nokia n9 furyu je range les badges en
même temps que je vous parle je pense
que vous avez vu ça pèse days de
mercedes et force à thiennes commençait
à en avoir un peu c'est une super
proposition donc je trouve de la part de
nokia c'est vraiment un smartphone qui
est hyper hyper hyper hyper intéressant
5 capteur photo à l'arrière un capteur
photo à l'avant pour le gros focus sont
les cinq capteurs photo à l'arrière
c'était showstoppers à barcelone et
forcément je rentre de barcelone dont
j'ai tous mes matches arrangés mais là
je sens que ça va finir par tomber
qu'est ce qui est intéressant avec ce
smartphone qu'est ce qu'il faut retenir
c'est que en fait vous avez un
partenariat entre nokia et elle ait
light pas si vous soulevez on a déjà
parlé
ils font des appareils photo avec plein
de capteurs photo bon l'idée c'est que
vous prenez une seule photo sur un sol
déclenchement vous avez une grande
possibilité derrière au niveau de
l'édition vous avez un choix qui
complètement hallucinant ça c'est
vraiment cool ça c'était le badge de
présentation 2009 ou de chiots mitrac
et du coup le fait que vous ayez 7 gala
cette pléthore ces grandes possibilités
vous permet de faire ce que vous voulez
ou à peu près ce que vous voulez à
quelque chose près et on finit vite chez
ça et je me pose et je raconte ouest ça
c'était mon badge bas du mwc c'est un
smartphone que j'ai pu prendre en main
pendant pas très longtemps mais que j'ai
pu découvrir que j'ai pu voir
fonctionner et je trouve que l'offre de
valeur derrière et hyper intéressante
alors c'est pas un smartphone qui est
destiné à tout le monde c'est un
smartphone qui est sur un marché qui est
hyper hyper hyper nicher c'est le marché
des photophones mais au delà si vous
voulez d'un smartphone comme un mail 20
pro on ne parlait que de lui ou alors du
dernier samsung enfin peu importe
l'offre est proposée par nos carrières
est un peu plus complexe
je vous explique pourquoi si on prend
monsieur madame tout le monde dont je
fais partie dont vous fait probablement
partie
c'est à dire que on n'a pas des besoins
en termes de smartphones qui vont être
complètement dingue
ce qu'on veut c'est un bon smartphone
qu'ils fassent de bonnes photos on veut
naviguer sur les réseaux sociaux notre
rapide avec un bel écran une belle
définition on veut pas s'emmerder on
veut que ce soit simple ça je dirais
c'est le besoin principal et c'est
justement là où ce smartphone va devenir
un petit peu trop complexe je mets des
grandes villes mais quand je dis ça et
j'espère me tromper
là je vous prends un smartphone qui est
un excellent photophone et notamment sur
les photos de nuit c'est le pic salle 3
ce qu'il faut réfléchir c'est qu'est ce
que vous faites qu'on voulait prendre
une photo eh bien vous voyez un truc
tiens ça c'est cool vous prenez votre
smartphone vous l'ouvrez vous mettez
dessus et classe vous faites une photo
ensuite votre photo vous la prenez vous
la mettez sur un star un filtre de
couleur sa part c'est terminé
bisous au revoir c'est comme ça qu'on
utilise nos appareils photos aujourd'hui
et c'est ça qui est vraiment cool on a
des appareils toujours plus performants
on a des smartphones toujours plus cool
avec un traitement logiciel toujours
plus optimisée on le prend en foot on en
voit et c'est simple je peux pas dire
que ce smartphone là et pas simple parce
que je n'ai franchement pas eu dans les
mains très longtemps mais derrière ce
convoi est ce qui fait la force de ce
smartphone c'est justement tout le
travail qu'on peut faire derrière en
post prod
ça c'est votre smartphone vous avez un
capteur là un capteur là un capteur l'a1
la voilà un la ola ça c'est flash ça
c'est la caméra tough qui vous sert pour
leur profondeur vous avez donc un
objectif là un objectif là un l'a1 là et
bien là
parmi ceux là vous en avez trois noirs
et blancs et vous en avez deux en
couleur tous ces capteurs là ce sont des
12 mégapixels qui ont exactement la même
ouverture de f 1.8 donc l'idée c'est
qu'à chaque fois que vous allez
déclenché ces cinq appareils vont faire
la même photo exactement au même moment
alors avec ça vous allez avoir des
points intéressants c'est à dire les
gars de luminosité com vous invite trois
capteurs noir et blanc vous allez
pouvoir avoir des photos noir et blanc
natif donc qu'ils vont pas se faire par
un traitement logiciel derrière et
surtout sa pouvoir déclencher plusieurs
fois rapidement et vous proposer en gros
d'aller travailler vos photos en post
prod l'idée si vous allez pouvoir avoir
un effet boké paramétrable logiciels en
gros lorsque vous allez avoir fait votre
photo lorsque vous allez la traiter
derrière soins dans votre smartphone
soit dans google photos vous allez
pouvoir régler la profondeur soit la
profondeur de champ sur barse et le
premier plan vous allez pouvoir faire un
flou plus ou moins accentuée derrière
soit un focus sur un élément derrière
que lui ait net l'autre plus flou devez
pouvoir régler le flou plus ou moins
floues
l'idée c'est que avec une cei même photo
vous allez vraiment choisir l'endroit
vous allez faire le point et ensuite
régler votre flou donc ça vous permet
une
d'une photo et vous allez pouvoir aller
beaucoup plus loin autant plus que vous
allez pouvoir avoir des photos au format
raw donc en haute définition ce qu'on
voit à travers ça si vous voulez c'est
qu'on est au final assez loin de
l'esprit je prends mon smartphone je
fais une photo et je la partage
au delà de ça le smartphone il a des
specs qui sont assez intéressantes vous
avez un écran paix au led qhd plus avec
une diagonale de 5,99 coude vous avez un
corning gorilla glass 5 à l'arrière et à
l'avant en plus qui coule en termes de
design vous avez aucun module photo qui
ressort à l'arrière ça c'est plutôt cool
ça va les protéger
vous tournez sur un dragon 845 si je
garde rab
lp ddr 428 giga de stockage bon ça c'est
le grand minimum de toute façon parce
que j'imagine que même la version
logicielle on n'est pas droit homme si
vous penchez votre tête vous saurez
pourquoi ce que ça va un peu mieux comme
ça 128 go de stockage
si vous prenez des photos en gros ça
c'est clair qu'il voulait faudra une
batterie de 3 milles 320 millions
terreur avec de la recharge sans fil et
vous pouvez regarder des vidéos au
format 4k hdr face à c'est plutôt cool
et un écran hd r10 et en nokia s'ils
vont regarder cette vidéo je suis
partante pour le tester comme ça je
pourrais en dire plus au final sur
l'expérience
au delà d'une petite prise en main
rapide dans le cadre d'un salon il
tourne sur android 9 pas il a un haut
parleur mono il se recharge en usb type
c'est également vous avez du bluetooth
5.0 une certification contre l'eau les
éclaboussures une certification ip67
voilà un peu pour le portrait robot ce
que je regrette
au-delà de l'aspect photo on sort un
petit peu de ça pas de prise jack bon
c'est pas hyper grave parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de fabricants de smartphones
qui aujourd'hui les supprime donc pas de
prise jack là dessus le fait qu'on ait
un dragon 845 montrait bien que c'est un
smartphone fin 2018 on en plus un
capteur d'empreinte digitale intégrée à
l'écran qui n'est pas un capteur
empreintes digitales ultrasons parce que
lui il est géré par le stade rigaud 855
et non pas par le 845
donc il y aura un petit peu moins vite
et si vous avez les doigts mouillés
il ne marchera pas bon ça c'est pas bien
grave après vous tapez votre code
polymorphe et tout ce que vous voulez
vous pourrez quand même le déverrouiller
soyez rassurés maintenant ce qui est
génial sur ce produit s'est
effectivement tous ces points positifs
parce que c'est un smartphone qui est
complètement optimisé
pour la photo et pour des photographes
pour des amateurs de photo et à mon avis
mais pour des photographes
professionnels qui veulent pas toujours
avoir leur reflex avec eux et à qui il
venait d'avoir un smartphone qui fait
d'excellentes photos peuvent vraiment
séduire par ce que la promesse qu'a
faite par ce smartphone c'est vraiment
de dire sortez votre smartphone vous
faites une photo vous prenez pas la tête
à faire vos réglages à faire beau si
vous prenez votre photo vous faites tous
vos réglages après de l'autre gros c'est
du punk and shoot ça ça marche
vous pointez vous chutez et on suit
derrière vous allez pouvoir venir
travailler votre photo pour vraiment
avoir ce que vous voulez pour ensuite
vraiment avoir l'image que vous voulez
donc on va en finale que ça smartphones
qui s'adresse pas du tout le monde qui à
mon avis est plutôt nicher et plutôt
ciblé et c'est pour ça que je dis que ce
smartphone va pas se mordre pas qu'il va
pas se vante pas que nokia va en vendre
aucun je pense pas mais ça va se vendre
très peu parce que on ne s'adresse pas
au grand public ce n'est pas une
proposition de valeur qui fait au grand
public lorsque le grand public y prend
un smartphone il shoote il partage on
n'en parle plus là on parle vraiment de
tout autre chose
on parle vraiment de prendre soin
d'éditer ses photos de vouloir chercher
la meilleure photo est vraiment passé du
temps dessus on s'adresse aux créateurs
aux créateurs de contenu aux
photographes ou photographes en herbe
d'autant plus avec un lightroom intégré
il est très clair que là dessus on
s'adresse à ses cibles là et comme je
vous le disais vous avez un flash vous
avez la caméra pts offre alors si ça
vous parle pas la caméra tough on l'a vu
arriver sur plusieurs smartphones c'est
la caméra time of light en gros c'est un
télémètre il va venir mesurer la
distance des objets et dans cette
fonctionnalité là il va vraiment venir
aider pour avoir des flous complètement
adapté parce qu'après on peut l'utiliser
notamment sur un honneur view 20 pour du
jeu vous allez pouvoir mesurer des
volumes le volume des sandwichs 30
calories paix intérieure va il ya pas
mal d'usagers
là on va vraiment l'utiliser pour aller
optimiser les photos alors au final je
trouve moi que c'est une proposition de
valeur qui est vraiment intéressante de
la part de nokia
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que le
marché du smartphone plus en plus
compliqué c'est très compliqué
j'aimerais vraiment pas être un
fabricant de smartphones aujourd'hui si
vous vous appelez pas au wawel samsung
ou apple c'est très très compliqué déjà
pour eux c'est pas hyper hyper évident
et si vous zappez nokia c'est dur
vous êtes un peu un outsider je dis pas
que nos cafés pas des bons produits et
je dis juste que aujourd'hui des ventes
de nokia on est très loin des ventes
d'un samsung wave d'apple ou même d'un
xiaomi c'est très très compliqué parce
que c'est un secteur qui vient de plus
en plus concurrentiel
il ya beaucoup d'acteurs dessus et du
coup l'offre s'appelle nokia on est
obligé de proposer des produits qui vont
être plus ni chez parce que si vous
proposer des produits généraliste vous
battez face à des monstres et en face
vous avez globalement très peu de
chances que ça marche nous en sortir ya
pas longtemps une nouvelle version de
leur 33-10 ça s'adressait vraiment aux
nostalgiques c'était évident que ce
smartphone n'allait pas se vendre
énormément mais sa part met un petit peu
de ne faire parler de la marque pareil
ils ont sorti le téléphone banane qu'on
a pu voir dans matrix l'idée c'est
effectivement avec ses petits outils la
dame en euros des outils comme nous
allons pouvoir faire le buzz assez
facilement ils savent qu'ils n'ont pas
en vendre des tonnes mais à côté de ça
permet de relancer la marque de jouer
sur la nostalgie dire attendez non les
télés ya longtemps on sait fabriquer on
sait faire on est de retour
donc voilà peu l'idée est là ce qui nous
propose avec un smartphone comme ça
c'est de dire on a compris que l' usage
principal temps un des usages principale
des smartphones c'est la photographie on
est bon en photo on vous le prouve et on
va vous montrer qu'on a un vrai savoir
faire à l'intérieur alors il en vrai
savoir-faire s'associe à light pour
effectivement à les optimiser cette
partie logicielle donc est ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est qu'on effectivement du
point de vue hardware sans capteur photo
derrière une partie logicielle qui
complètement optimisé pouvez faire ce
que vous voulez du moins c'est la
promesse qu'ils aient fait d'ailleurs
j'aimerais vraiment tester donc nokia ou
rim envoyer un petit mail je suis
preneur pour ensuite aller tester ce
nokia 9 pur view je sais pas ce que vous
en pensez vous est-ce que ce que je vous
dis ça fait sens pour vous est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec moi est ce que
ce nokia 9 pur view est un smartphone
qui au final ne va pas se vendre
énormément parce qu'il est riche et mais
s'adresse vraiment à une cible qui est
pas très grande et même dans cette cible
là vous êtes en concurrence fasse un
mail 20 prône qui va être très bon en
photographie et qui sera plus dans
l'idée portel shoot vous faites la photo
vous la prenez vous la partagez vous est
peut-être moins d'un village derrière
mais vous vous en mettez un peu moins
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en en
commentaire je pense qu'on en reparlera
parce que je trouve que cette
proposition est vraiment intéressante y
avoir pas mal de choses à dire dessus
si la portez vous bien
vous embrasse et à demain ciao